avec nous jean charles le cachons
professeur de stratégie des
organisations à la faculté de gestion de
l'université laurentienne à sudbury se
cachant bonsoir bonsoir
quelle est votre analyse de ce qui s'est
passé avec stornoway pour qu'on se
retrouve dans cette situation bien je
pense qu'il ya deux facteurs qui jouent
en défaveur de l'entreprise le premier
évidemment c'est que c'est une mine qui
a été inaugurée en 2017 qui a coûté au
dessus de 700 millions donc l'entreprise
est très endetté d'une part d'autre part
étant donné que c'est une entreprise en
démarrage
elle a accumulé des pertes au cours des
deux dernières années et elle vient de
sortir au début de cette année avec des
bénéfices d'exploitation
mais étant donné les lourdes dettes à
rembourser
évidemment il y a encore des pertes
nettes
la deuxième chose c'est que la
conjoncture pour le diamant canadien
n'est pas bonne dans le sens où les
entreprises canadiennes produisent des
petits diamants qui se vendent à des
prix relativement bas
d'une part parce que la demande mondiale
est plus faible que d'habitude en partie
parce que le l'économie indienne
notamment la roupie indienne est en
baisse par rapport aux autres monnaies
donc les acheteurs indiens qui
représente un groupe assez important sur
le marché mondial sont moins nombreux et
achètent moins de petits diamants
d'autre part parce que les producteurs
canadiens ont du mal à vendre leurs
produits comparativement aux producteurs
d'autres pays qui souvent produisent en
fait des diamants plus gros donc ont
tendance à aller chercher des prix
hocquart a beaucoup plus élevés que les
prix obtenus par les producteurs
canadiens
là maintenant avec investissement québec
et au cisco qui projette donc deux avec
d'autres créanciers mais principalement
investissement québec qui est aussi ce
qu de gérer cette entreprise à partir de
maintenant est ce que est ce qu'on va
restructurer stornoway ce que ce temps
là où il va se retrouver dans une bien
meilleure position
eh bien je pense que les d'une part bien
sûr le fait de recapitaliser
éventuellement l'entreprise va lui
permettre de faire face à ses
obligations financières
du point de vue de la dette par contre
le marché
peut-être que si si cette firme peut
être peu modifié et ses manières de
faire pour peut-être sortir ou
rechercher un plus grand nombre de gros
diamant par rapport aux petits modèles
qu'on est en train de compléter en train
de produire jusqu'à maintenant
donc si on arrive à identifier des plus
gros diamants qui pourront aller
chercher des valeurs au carat plus élevé
si elle cadet des mines notamment situés
au botswana à ce moment là on pourra
faire une meilleure concurrence aux
sociétés minières africaines en
particulier et russe également
donc est-ce que jusqu'à un certain point
est ce que vous nous dites que ce marché
là des petites via main n'est pas aussi
attrayant qu'on voudrait qu'ils le
soient tout à fait il ya cet élément là
deuxièmement il faut dire que
l'industrie canadienne du diamant est
une industrie jeune il ya certaines
entreprises qui sont présentes au canada
qui sont là surtout pour diversifier
leurs sources d'approvisionnement
demant parce que justement elle se
trouve très dépendante des mines
africaines et donc elle cherche à avoir
d'autres sources de produits par contre
les propriétaires canadiens eux mêmes
évidemment se retrouve un peu isolée par
rapport à des grandes firmes qui sont
leurs concurrentes et n'ont pas toujours
réussi à développer le marché autant
qu'il le voudrait souvent à cause de
leur petite taille
est ce que le gouvernement du québec s
qu'investissement québec pourront
récupérer les quelque 440 millions de
dollars d'argent public qui ont été
investis dans ce tournoi oui ça reste
une grande question parce que pour
l'instant évidemment la situation n'est
pas n'est pas brillante mais les marchés
dès les marchés des pierres précieuses
sont des marchés qui sont relativement
volatile d'une part mais d'autre part
qui sont très fragmenté donc si on
arrive à restructurer la production et
si on arrive également à influer sur les
méthodes de marketing de l'entreprise à
ce moment là il est possible que l'on
puisse tirer l'épinglé du jeu
aujourd'hui vous regardez en tête
elle écrit donc je pense qu'il faut
garder en tête aussi le fait que dont on
est dans un contexte de taux d'intérêt
relativement bas
évidemment une entreprise comme celle là
ne peut pas profiter de taux très bas à
cause de son niveau d'endettement et à
cause de son niveau de risque très élevé
mais la présence de ces investisseurs
importants va peut-être permettre
justement de réduire le niveau de risque
de l'entreprise et à ce moment là lui
permettent peut-être d'avoir des frais
financiers moins élevé il est clair cela
dit un regard de la déclaration de
stornoway aujourd'hui elle a dit
clairement que les petits actionnaires
n'auraient pas grand chose ou à peu près
rien
il n'y aura aucune valeur recouvrable ou
résiduelles à l'égard des actions
ordinaires ou d'aidés pentures
convertibles de stone oui ça demeure
extrêmement risqué pour des petits
actionnaires n'est ce pas oui en fait le
secteur minier en général quand on parle
de d'entre d'eux d'entreprises
relativement petite qui démarre avec des
projets de ce genre là c'est clair qu'il
ya un facteur de risque beaucoup plus
élevé que dans dix domaines beaucoup
plus traditionnelle donc effectivement
et d'autre part l'action stornoway a été
rayé de la bourse de toronto
il ya quelques jours donc évidemment
c'est une situation catastrophique de ce
côté là pour les actionnaires il n'y a
absolument aucun doute monsieur cachant
merci beaucoup pour cette analyse ce
soir merci bonne soirée